we've got a box I got a big-ass box I've
been waiting for this for so long I'm so
excited I know what's inside you
probably know what's inside as well
because I spoiled it in thumbnail but
hey what do you say old pal should we
open it up tripod bro this just got a
lot harder to film [ __ ] god damn boy god
damn that's a big box I don't even know
how to open it Jesus crying I never got
a package like this I get package it
again I'm doing the unboxing here how do
I open it whoa does it just come up oh
my god he does are we ready for the
first layer boy Oh again so excited are
you from a scale from one to ten answer
right now
wow that's amazing wah oh my god
how do I get this okay I don't I don't
want to break it
the box is so nice I don't want to break
it
oh oh my god oh my god it is so sexy oh
my god it's so happy I'm going for it
ahh
myself Swedish do not drop this killer
you're not right with all your mic oh my
god it's so I'm so scared
I never been too scared this is my life
my life it didn't throw my garlic so
happy oh limited oh ah
put it down [ __ ] Jesse no no I don't
need to work out shut up are you guys
ready to see this bad boy oh my god I'm
seeing a little sneak sneak peeks no boy
you better not pee on this
I got peed on the box you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I think we're ready for the big
reveal
yeah get in the shock in there why don't
you get in the shot here we go here we
go Wow nice oh my god oh my god oh my
lord oh my custom custom printed prepaid
designed desktop this thing is a goddamn
beast okay have a look on the side it's
got a warning on it that's cool this is
the coolest computer I have ever seen I
am so proud to be owning this computer
when I started YouTube I spent all my
money on my computer I get started
Oh
let's be careful here now damn damn look
at that cooling berth not cooling though
my God my god okay well it get loves it
my God thank you for the computer piers
I love it the fans have had Bayes on
them yes what a nicely timed loaning sad
pep a way to summarize the last few
months so main Guerra asked me about the
design and I wanted to keep my like
psychedelic design that I've been using
unlike my happy socks and all that it's
the same they used on like cars so it's
legit my god so yeah we wanted to be
like sleepy inspired so nice little
touch with back
you don't even have to know anything
about computers to see that this is a
god damn it's a David you know it's a
masterpiece the Mona Lisa holy [ __ ] I
can't wait to just plug it in and see
how it looks like and how it runs
I know it's got two Titans in it which
is ridiculous
I'll I'll post the specs in the
description but holy [ __ ] [ __ ] it
looks so good
you know things main gear for not just
entertaining me but my dog as well I
really appreciate it
they also sent me this box which I sing
that's all the cable they sent it from
America they sent it on Tuesday and
arrived Friday what kind of what kind of
shifting is that like teleportation hey
we got manger stuff
no thank you
a blu-ray writer why is that separate
hey I'll take it that's my logo on it
I didn't see that are you guys anxious
watching me do this or is this enjoyable
of this fix now the problem is I got to
get this into my office it's going to be
messy go oh my god my god
alright so now I just got to plug all
the cables that go from my old computer
to my new computer I decided to put on
this side because then you see the
interior this thing is too cool for my
office ok I'm not worthy of this goddamn
thing such a [ __ ] mess dad [ __ ] you
damn it what is that
big what I thought ok stop stop fighting
with me
you're in [ __ ] Ethernet cable you
don't even go anywhere I'm talking don't
even want you know what what does it
even go god damn it I hate capable
technically I could just plug it start
it up now should I do that like a little
pretty start nothing happened well ok
there an unbuttoned there must be an on
line that Jesus alright now I just got
to put these cables and there shouldn't
be any problem god I love being a
youtuber having too many cables where do
these cables even [ __ ] go like where
do you go I'm sweating okay I'm [ __ ]
sweating so much because I'm putting in
tables cables is making me so hey we got
the light back everyone that's that's
progress I would say I think I plug that
into itself
I'm a genius I got sure you cuz it looks
so [ __ ] eating there
it's so nicely done even with all the
colors it's such a detail it's got two
[ __ ] Titans boy all right
they're all plugged in I just need to
find the on button with an bun I feel
like such an idiot I think I found the
on button are you ready nothing happened
really okay I found some more stuffs
that was hidden in that giant math box
looks like all the cannonballs more
cable American cable we also have this
fold the manuals how do I start this
computer I don't know
[ __ ] hell I wonder if I'll have to go
to the motherboard yes okay
whoo you hear that liquid cooling the
peppers are spinning my god oh my god
it's a lot oh [ __ ] race to the Beast
I think I'm calling our best thing back
to the Beast race to the Beast damn damn
what really matters is what sleepy
things whoa Jesus
all right sleepy do you want to check it
out perhaps he loves it don't go in
there having a toad as a pet is very
exciting as sleepy is very infatuated by
his computer maybe it's your computer
you can have it he's only treat by it
I'm a little worried that he's going to
jump inside all right what an adventure
guys I'm going to put sleepy away before
you get too pissed off at me always
great to have a pet that despises you
and this feels a bit you know when
people make these car videos on YouTube
when they show off their car you know I
don't really care for cars but this is
definitely something that I feel really
proud to show often looking back when I
started YouTube
the computer I had then compared to you
know I never thought I would own a
computer like this it is absolutely
incredible it's like more than I ever
need but at the same time in the best
possible way so I got to give a huge
things obviously two main gear for
hooking me up really cool guys working
there and if you want the same setup you
can buy it as well but if you just want
to get something simpler as well I
recommend checking them out they have
really good products this is not a
sponsored video obviously I did get the
computer I didn't have to make a video
or anything but anyway I'm going to sort
out my cable management now for a couple
hours and I don't think you need guys
need to see that but I hope you enjoyed
leave a like if you did and really thank
you brofist alright it's day two didn't
think this would have it's part two but
I spent a couple hours just getting the
[ __ ] cable management done and now oh
my god
it's very [ __ ] nice okay stay and
look at that boy that's obviously what
the cameras supposed to be this is now
my setup I changed to razor I thought it
why not man it's just [ __ ] nice it's
just really nice especially having the
computer as well
the cables all going down but about them
nice and tidy one point for me zero
points two cables
[ __ ] you cables you ain't get nothing on
me nothing
[ __ ] you what does it look like behind
the screens oh that's right neatly tie
okay well it doesn't look that nice but
it is that is really tidy jefe
goddamn I'm so happy we just setup it's
not perfect but it's got damn [ __ ]
nice
I want to show you one more thing all
right so on this floor we finally have
set up this cost the [ __ ] fortune but
look at that all the way all the way
around it even goes there and then we
have a green screen and then a white
screen and we can pull you can pull all
the way all the way pretty cool so
basically what we're going to do with
this space is I don't know if I should
say it we're gonna livestream I know
exciting I really I'm really looking
forward to it doing like a livestream
show I tried it before but it never
really worked out but I hope now with
some help we can do like a weekly
livestream I think that would be really
fun I think I I'm really excited for it
I think you guys are going to like it
that's what's happening now you'll know
all the ins and outs Oh in the best part
not the same goddamn awful tripod thank
you look at that boy doesn't [ __ ]
move namaste to main gear check them out
I'll link them in the description I
forgot to mention if you guys want to
get the very same computer or another
one over at main gear when you check out
be sure to enter the code PewDiePie and
you'll get a free two-year warranty and
free shipping which is pretty awesome so
definitely be sure to use that if you
want to make a purchase also if you got
no money there might still be luck for
you because we're doing a giveaway we're
giving away one of these beautiful
beasts just go to main gear comm slash
giveaway I'll link all of this in the
description follow these instructions
and one of you and might be the lucky
one I really recommend and recommend
yeah and then now I'm just going to
record another [ __ ] video for you
press this is Peter pot signing off with
a brofist